i holdings pessoais de quem fala andar
que sejam muito bem vindos é mais um
vídeo e sim eu adoro os bonecos a helbor
é o senhor é o amor é o senhor é o que é
diferente que é correr atrás com bola
pra frente você é livre e eu fico
diferente que constitui uma idéia que
tem uma lâmpada no meu livro na internet
à procura de jogos para jogar coisas
novas para fazer é e não encontrei [ __ ]
nenhuma
sabia que eu tive de 360 graus que vocês
podem ver tudo à nossa volta mexer lá o
rato em tudo sabe tanque tu podes vir em
65 graus mas não só viola tipo pode ver
os vídeos com os foquem do com os hits
será que no fim vamos investigar e lá
foi o da área à procura de um programa
que os nossos vídeos 260 num jogo típico
por acaso também ventos ante 61 já viram
coincidência eu descobri que sintap
vídeos de 260 nos jogos fifa e é isso
que vou fazer o japão
basicamente filho vai ser o começo de
uma série que foi chamado e ação em 360
graus é eu vi que os livres primeiro
episódio é faxinais é fredes por sentir
certa eu já cheguei pra ser feliz não só
conseguiu retornar para caraças pois
nunca nenhum filme tempo real com os
personagens pagar fredes aqui dentro por
isso eu acho que isso vai mudar mais no
dia 3/5 neco leunam para há muito tempo
que eu não jogava aqui mesmo de eu estar
tudo preto está a funcionar há ou não o
chip por onde pessoal vídeo está pronto
para lá 321 vai besta spinning sido
iphan um desafio mas é fredes sharland a
supostamente estão shalom cair então eu
vou ter que aguentar o vídeo tudo até o
fim né
e se eu te amo rúa o olhar sofreu em
casa e os rios que conforto pelos
analistas falam ainda vou falar eu vou
tentar prestar atenção a valorização do
iene ea mês em 1 a 1
meu deus
dez anos esteve aqui é mais o ronaldo o
início é sic sabe se vai dar ok eu só
não destrói as câmeras o dólar vinha só
acabou já que eu gosto
somente então não tinha antes eu vou
contar até o fim sua basicamente o que
eu disse foi que ela não trabalhava no
photo finish fredes trabalhar um fato de
esses fatos e por seu e agora está nos
traz gravações da câmera nas quebras que
estão aqui em casa eu supostamente está
a passar agora pelo músico em agora sim
meu deus não não estava em ao pessoal eu
não sei se vocês têm noção mas tá muito
ruim comenta casa meu corpo assim olha e
máquina de lavar e eu caí que está tudo
bem
um armário camas paneolio tá muita coisa
aí é muita informação aqui para observar
dois quando fui assim e só vocês viram
um frame um sistema para vencer o boni
pessoal refere à visão
a fama fora porque alguém a reprodutora
brilho aí por ora taxa poderá
transformar outras que não sabem então
acho que ou a porta do lado fora abriu a
porta o blog foi abril com alguma coisa
aí por votação chinelo foi qualquer
coisa contra mim meu estava enviando tá
muito real
nenê anotou o quarto
voltamos pro quarto aqui está tudo bem
qualquer coisa me mexer tão um gato com
só então falei a porta abriu abriu ainda
mais o clube
o tabu em algum canto da manhã e
apagaram as luzes
o ou não está muito bom tá muito bom não
é assim tanto medo mas tabu e elson
olha aí a mãe vai para se transformar em
um prazo não só sai tudo bom
no que toca à aidan elliott por 3 a 3
não longe hoje pra eu entrar por seu e
agora 1 mil vai irradiar licença até
parte esposa ó suave era só isso
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque
o speedy espero que vocês tenham gostado
de ver como é que vocês acham que eu
continuar nesta série mais vídeos de 360
postos podem que a própria inter
facebook esse objeto qualquer coisa mas
nem isso quanto como é que tudo isto
fique bem e até a próxima